[Music]
the most crucial part of filmmaking is
that it's a collaboration and and and
the actors and the director and the
designers and the DOP everybody has to
that has to be on the same page
and they have to be able to communicate
they have to be able to give feedback to
one another
accept that feedback throw out more
feedback so on and so forth it has to be
a give-and-take you're constructing
something you're building something
you're building towards something but
then as you go through that process
you're tearing it down again you're
deconstructing it building it back up
again in a different way you have to be
prepared whenever you're going to make a
movie to just throw anything and
everything out of the window at any
point during that process that's your
primary obligation but it's it's it's
it's apps of absolute necessity that you
be prepared to do that as a filmmaker
don't be precious and during that
process you you find that things are oh
that the thing that you're trying to
create is always changing it's always in
flux and that ultimately it really is
never really finished I'm also a big fan
of not cutting unless I really feel it's
necessary and forging ahead and having
somebody repeat lines and having
somebody I'll say okay now go back to
the beginning of that monologue and just
do it again do it again and just do the
whole thing with your eyes closed or
whatever just to keep the camera rolling
and so that otherwise what happens is
people start to think too much and
thought can be the absolute the death of
creativity and then everybody else on
the stet starts doing this they start
grabbing the thing and they start
adjusting it and the guy comes in with
the makeup and the thing comes in with
the hair and the and that's ten minutes
and all the energy is drawn and the
actors concentration is gone
and we've lost time you hope for a
certain budget you usually don't get it
you get maybe close to it but you know
what your bottom line is you know like
okay I can make this movie for blah blah
blah I really can't make it for less
than that because then it just becomes
it it won't look good it won't it just
won't work so you have to know what your
bottom line is and that's basically what
you usually end up with a movie like
this once you have that you you have to
stick to it and I'm very happy to spend
to overspend my own money but I'm not
interested in over spending somebody
else's money I'm only interested in
coming in under or on budget and I
rather like those restraints because
throwing money at a problem doesn't
always solve that problem as is
evidenced in so many bigger films the
the idea of restraints constrictions
restrictions they only engender
creativity as far as I'm concerned so
and again if you have the right team who
go on I know what to do I know what to
do
just give me that pillar that we used
and for the set on blah blah blah we'll
take it paint it green stick it over
here and put the bush in front of it and
nobody will ever know and this is what's
done and people don't know I mean if you
have really good people they don't know
if you have really bad people you can
sort of go oh that's that same pillar
Panthers green with the bush in front of
it but I think it's really just all
about imagination
it's about imagination and creativity
finding somebody with whom to
collaborate sometimes is necessary
sometimes you don't need it sometimes
too but you think you need it but you
don't need it
which is why you see a lot of times
people will sort of pair up and then
someday they end up do a couple of
projects than they end up going their
separate ways because they they took
something that they needed from each
other at that time
and then once they sort of got it they
went they could go their own ways I
think if you look at the example of
Picasso Picasso was like a thief like a
sponge like a thief who was a spy like a
sponge thief was Emig anything he was if
you look at his his trajectory he sort
of aligned himself with juan gris who
was the great cubist julio gonzales who
was a great gonzales was a great
sculptor he befriended all of these
people and sort of took from them what
he needed in order to do what he wanted
to do and learn from them and then go
from there
that's part of what you do when you what
you do when you're younger but sometimes
you know sometimes if you just take a
beat you may realize that you don't
really need that it's very rare to find
a collaboration that lasts for longer
than a couple three projects I think
it's very unusual but I think you're
looking for somebody always who is going
to not just be a yes-man but somebody
who's gonna challenge you who has who
shares an aesthetic but who who's really
gonna challenge you was really gonna
question you it was really gonna say
well why is that line necessary why do
you want that shot in there
what does that shot mean and you have to
be able to do that to that person too
and I think every artist goes through I
mean and there's it's you know it's in
the film as part of this this film
final portrait where Giacometti is
incredibly self downing and and
self-effacing and self-loathing even I
think that we all have that and then we
have these moments of oh I really am
good
I do I really do know what I really am
okay and I'm good at this and then you
have those moments where you go I have
no idea what I'm doing why have I ever
chosen this profession it's simply a
matter of I don't know that you can ever
get to the point where you can balance
it out but having a good support system
and sort of taking a deep breath and
maybe looking back on you know what you
have achieved without resting on laurels
is it's not a terrible idea sometimes
[Music]
you